now it's important to remember that
we're not here to teach you how to build
a weather app it's not even to teach you
all of the Android API is that we'll use
to build it it's really about retraining
your brain to start thinking like a
mobile developer which is really
important because at the end of this
course we're going to ask you to build
your own final project we're expecting
you to already be familiar with
object-oriented programming and to have
experience with Java or a similar
language personally I got started with
Android after years of Delfy and c-sharp
development as engineers were trained to
map our experiences in one language or
SDK into nuance looking for patterns and
shortcuts we can get up to speed as
quickly as possible but mobile and
Android in particular has some
fundamental differences that mean some
of our experience and intuition will
actually make us worse mobile engineers
we like to think of smartphones as
computers that fit into our pockets in a
way that's true but their computers from
the 90s like this powerhouse I was using
nearly 20 years ago with limited
internet connectivity
low-speed CPUs and limited RAM on top of
which they're all running on batteries
as we go through the course I'll be
returning to each of these key mobile
challenges looking for places where your
experience on desktop or server or even
other mobile platforms might lead you in
the wrong direction
I'll also be back to tell you some
stories from the early days of Android
stories that describe how the Android
platform has evolved and nowhere is that
more readily apparent than here at the
Android lawn sculpture garden
join me here at the very heart of
Android at the end of this lesson to
find out how this sculpture garden of
tasty treats also tells the story of
androids history for now let's get back
to building that weather app so we'll
cross to Dan to take a look at some
mocks